Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
À qui profite la théorie du complot ?
À qui ça profite ?
Vous vous êtes déjà posé cette question ?
On ne la pose jamais, ou rarement,
pourtant elle n’est pas illégitime
à un moment où on parle de plus en plus
de théorie du complot,
du complotisme, du conspirationnisme.
Évidemment, ce n’est pas nouveau.
On en connaît tous :
sur des événements historiques,
le 11 septembre, dont on fêtait le triste
vingtième anniversaire récemment,
la Révolution française aussi,
les deux guerres mondiales,
tous les événements marquants en général.
Il y en a sur des technologies,
des théories du complot : la 5G,
les vaccins ARN messagers, etc.
Vous en avez sur des phénomènes
naturels ou physiques,
comme par exemple les traînées blanches
que les avions laissent dans le ciel
après leur passage, il y a
des théories du complot là-dessus.
Puis vous avez des théories du complot
qui réinterprètent radicalement
ce que nous croyons être la réalité.
Par exemple sur la forme de la
Terre qui est sous nos pieds,
des théories du complot
qui peuvent porter sur des entités :
Big Pharma, on en a beaucoup
entendu parler ces derniers 18 mois,
la CIA, les banques...
sur des groupes humains également,
les francs-maçons, les Juifs,
sur des groupes
qui n’existent pas également.
Vous avez peut-être entendu parler
des extra-terrestres reptiliens
qui contrôleraient le monde
en secret, ou les Illuminati.
Jusqu’à preuve du contraire,
ça n’existe pas.
Ces théories du complot
ont toutes un point commun,
ce sont toujours
des discours d’accusation.
Elles pointent un doigt accusateur
en direction d’un petit groupe d’individus
accusés de quoi ? De comploter,
c’est-à-dire de se livrer
à un acte foncièrement malveillant,
répréhensible, sinon légalement,
du moins moralement.
Et pour cette raison-là,
le complotisme est un sujet
qui a une dimension politique,
éminemment, irréductiblement politique,
qui a rapport avec la violence
et avec le pouvoir.
Et c’est aussi la raison pour laquelle
le complotisme a toujours été utilisé
et continue d’être utilisé
par des démagogues pour flatter le peuple,
pour lui désigner des boucs émissaires
à stigmatiser, à persécuter,
par des régimes autoritaires aussi
pour disqualifier leurs opposants,
la Cinquième colonne,
l’ennemi de l’intérieur, et aussi surtout,
pour voiler, masquer leurs propres échecs.
Alors pourquoi parle-t-on autant
de la théorie du complot, du complotisme
ces dernières années ?
Il y a une thèse qui dit que finalement,
tout ça est une bulle médiatique
entretenue pour d’obscures raisons
par les journalistes, les médias, etc.
Moi, je crois l’inverse.
Je crois qu’on est là
face à un phénomène tangible
et que le complotisme nous influence
plus qu’il nous influençait auparavant.
Et quand je dis auparavant,
je dis avant Internet,
tout simplement parce que
nous y sommes plus exposés
et parce qu’on ne peut pas
penser un phénomène
comme le platisme ou le complotisme
en le dissociant de ses conditions
matérielles, techniques, de diffusion.
Le platisme, par exemple, il y a 20 ans,
10 ans, était extrêmement marginal,
extrêmement minoritaire,
il y en avait très peu.
Aujourd’hui, des groupes de platistes
non seulement sur Internet,
mais dans la vie réelle,
qui se réunissent chaque année,
presque chaque année,
au Brésil ou aux États-Unis,
tout autour du globe.
(Rires)
Et ça, on ne peut pas le penser
si on ne comprend pas qu’Internet
et pas seulement Internet, mais cette
configuration technique médiatique
très particulière,
qui repose sur un triptyque -
le haut débit, les réseaux
sociaux et les smartphones -
a tout changé dans nos manières d’accéder
à la connaissance, à l’information.
Parce qu’avec ces outils-là,
d’abord, on peut trouver littéralement
toutes les versions alternatives
sur à peu près n’importe quel sujet.
Vous cherchez une théorie
du complot, vous la trouverez
avec une connexion et avec un moteur
de recherche comme Google.
Et puis, surtout, les réseaux sociaux
vous mettent en contact, en relation,
avec des gens qui croient aussi,
comme vous,
ce genre de choses et donc vous permettent
de faire communauté avec des gens
que vous allez vous aussi influencer,
dont vous allez alimenter les croyances,
et qui vont vous alimenter en retour.
Et puis, c’est très facile de relayer,
de partager ces choses-là massivement
parce qu’avec nos smartphones,
on peut littéralement
partager à des millions d’individus
ces choses-là.
En regard, vous avez ces plateformes
de réseaux sociaux, de vidéos en ligne,
dont les algorithmes sont friands
de théories du complot.
Pas parce qu’ils sont complotistes,
mais ils aiment le sensationnalisme.
Les contenus complotistes sont
particulièrement sensationnalistes
puisqu’ils vous expliquent
qu’on vous cache la vérité
sur tel ou tel événement,
ils prétendent vous révéler la vérité.
Donc évidemment, cette configuration,
au final, elle donne une chance
historique au complotisme.
À ce stade, on pourrait se dire :
«Mais finalement,
est-ce que c’est si grave ?
Est-ce que c’est si grave
parce que tout ça est ridicule ?
Ces histoires rigolotes,
mais qui prend ça au sérieux ?»
Mais de plus en plus de gens
prennent ça au sérieux,
ça a des conséquences graves, ça en a eu
par le passé, ça continue à en avoir.
On sait le rôle, par exemple,
du complotisme dans la radicalisation
politique, politico-religieuse,
terroriste également.
On sait son rôle
dans l’enfermement sectaire,
y compris dans des phénomènes
de désocialisation
où des gens se retrouvent
H24 sur leur écran d’ordinateur
rompant tous les liens
avec leur famille, leurs amis.
Des familles brisées, des gens
qui n’arrivent plus à communiquer,
qui coupent les ponts parce qu’ils ne
peuvent plus vraiment communiquer.
Et puis, le complotisme est aussi utilisé
comme un travail de sape de la démocratie.
L’un des pionniers de la réflexion
sur le sujet, un historien américain
qui s’appelait Richard Hofstadter, qui,
dès les années 60, avait bien vu que...
En substance, il expliquait que lorsque
matin, midi et soir, vous êtes exposé
à des fausses informations qui suggèrent
que vos représentants
démocratiquement élus
sont des pantins à la solde
de puissances obscures,
que le vrai pouvoir se joue ailleurs,
que la vérité est ailleurs,
que le pouvoir est invisible,
que tout se joue dans les coulisses,
que la démocratie est un théâtre d’ombres.
Eh bien, vous en arrivez logiquement,
presque fatalement, à remettre en cause
la validité du système qui permet cela,
c’est-à-dire de la démocratie libérale.
Le système qui fait notre prospérité
depuis la fin
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Et puis,
ce complotisme vient exacerber
les tensions et les antagonismes
qui travaillent nos sociétés en les
polarisant au point de faire éclater
une partie de ce socle de réalités
que nous avons en partage,
ce que la philosophe Hannah Arendt
appelait «le monde commun».
Or, que devient le débat démocratique
lorsqu’il n’y a plus de monde commun ?
Il se condamne à être
un dialogue de sourds.
On ne peut plus définir ensemble
le bien commun
si on ne partage même plus
la même réalité.
Et ça a des conséquences.
Parce que si on ne tranche plus
nos désaccords par les mots, par le débat,
par la parole,
il ne reste que la violence.
Et c’est ce qui s’est passé en janvier
2021 aux États-Unis, lorsque
des partisans de Donald Trump,
chauffés à blanc,
persuadés qu’on leur avait
volé l’élection,
se sont insurgés, sont montés
à l’assaut du Capitole,
c’est-à-dire l’un des endroits les plus
sacrés de la démocratie américaine.
Et ce qui avait commencé comme un mensonge
complotiste a fini dans le sang.
Il y a eu des morts au Capitole
et c’est la première fois
que ça se passe comme ça,
qu’une alternance démocratique
se passe de manière aussi tragique
aux États-Unis depuis le 18e siècle.
Donc, le complotisme, c’est un discours
de diversion qui, en plus,
diffère notre prise de conscience
collective sur les vrais défis
auxquels nous sommes confrontés.
Ces vrais défis, vous les connaissez :
le réchauffement climatique,
le terrorisme,
la santé publique.
Regardez le rôle du complotisme
par exemple dans la défiance
et dans la propagande anti-vaccination.
Et en fait, le grand paradoxe
du complotisme, c’est que,
en canalisant notre indignation
vers de fausses manipulations,
des manipulations inventées, imaginaires,
eh bien, il nous manipule.
En fait, la seule manipulation,
elle est là.
Alors, à qui profite
les théories du complot ?
Vous avez compris à des charlatans
qui monétisent leur chaîne YouTube
complotiste, lèvent des fonds
sur les plateformes de crowdfunding
pour faire encore plus
de contenus complotistes.
Elles profitent, ces théories du complot,
aux illuminés, parfois, aux ennemis
de la démocratie, toujours,
et en tout cas à des gens qui ont
un agenda, un projet politique.
Donc, si j’avais un message à faire
passer ce soir, ce serait
que le complotisme a un coût
et ce coût n’est pas neutre.
Sans même parler du coût financier
du complotisme, certains l’ont estimé
à plusieurs dizaines de milliards d’euros
par an pour nos sociétés.
Non, non, il a un coût
parce que votre attention,
le temps que vous passez connecté,
votre temps de cerveau disponible en fait,
il n’est pas illimité, il est fini,
donc il est précieux.
Et le temps que vous accordez
aux fake news, aux théories du complot,
c’est concrètement du temps qui est pris
sur la connaissance validée
scientifiquement,
sur l’information à haute valeur ajoutée
que des bataillons de chercheurs,
de scientifiques, de savants,
de journalistes, s’épuisent à produire,
parfois au péril de leur vie.
Ils y laissent parfois
effectivement leur vie.
Donc, je ne peux que vous encourager
à faire barrage à la théorie du complot,
à vous engager
à ce qu’elle ne passe pas par vous.
Par exemple, en vous abstenant de partager
un contenu douteux
issu d’une source peu fiable,
d’un média peu fiable,
juste avec un geste comme celui-là,
un geste d’abstention.
Si vous ne le faites pas
pour la démocratie ou  la concorde civile,
si vous ne le faites pas
pour la santé publique,
faites-le au moins
pour votre amour-propre.
Parce que la théorie du complot,
c’est un piège intellectuel,
c’est un leurre.
c'est un mirage et un mirage dangereux.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)